this must be extra special for you
because you co-wrote all 16 songs I did
and it's a journey about your life
definitely is what was that trip like
for you to go down memory lane this this
is really my first record that I've
written every song on the record on my
past records there's always been a
couple of songs that were kind of
outside written songs that I really fell
in love with but on this one I felt like
just really needed to be told by me the
narrator and Center Point Road is a
little street that I grew up on yeah 20
minutes north of Nashville Tennessee and
just so much nostalgia you know I'm
saying like drove that road to school to
football practice to pick up somebody on
a first date first kiss first breakup
first failures first thing everything
that happened in that little town shaped
you know who i am today is a 29 year old
person and i got to take a lot of just
inspiration from from growing up and and
making some really unique cool songs
about it today so did you go back and
kind of write as you're walking around
and like this is where I had my first
where was your first kiss do you
remember the girl's name
Jenny Roden there you go that's
impressive I was on the cheek that was
it wasn't real yeah songs as you were
just kind of walking around and kind of
write most of my songs on the bus
because when I get back home on a Sunday
from the road my wife's like you're not
going anywhere you know you're gonna
stay right here and so so when I go on
the road and my kids aren't with me I'll
bring riders from Nashville and we'll
write you know nine or ten songs a
weekend and and so by the time you're
about to record a record you're looking
at like you know 150 songs then you got
a little down to you know 20 yeah but
that's my favorite part of the process
is really identifying what what are your
what are the Great's of the good so and
I love your single is absolutely you so
much how would you describe the music of
this this album the sound of it because
I do feel there's a little bit of pop to
it yeah there's a little bit of can I
say R&B to it absolutely yeah that would
be a compliment there is that touch of
it when you listen to it I mean I when I
listen to me as I close my eyes and kind
of listen to the vibe of it how would
you describe the sound of it I think you
nailed it
oh did I yeah I mean yeah every every
record we've evolved more and more and
always have tried to just kind of push
myself to explore different ways of
production different melody different
lyrical content
and so on this one there's a lot of
songs that are a little bit more rootsy
than I've done the last couple albums
that kind of remind me of my first
record a little bit which is cool but
then there's a lot of songs that are
very pop influenced very arm be
influenced very Tom Petty rock and roll
and influenced and I just grew up
listening to so many different kinds of
music that obviously country music is my
first love and will always be but I grew
up listening to so many different kinds
of music and go into you know my first
concert ever was the Rolling Stones and
then oh yeah pretty sick yeah and my
second was the darkness band
god yes so like I grew up loving rock
and roll and hip hop and R&B and so it
naturally just kind of flows out of me
when I'm making record making records it
seems like a lot of country stars want
to do that they want to go into that
another world like Taylor Swift for
example is that something you want to do
next in your next albums as well you
know I think whatever happens to my
music I just wanted to happen
organically
you know I mean like I just want to make
sure that I put my stamp on my record
and if it happens to to cross those
lines then that's cool but I'm just kind
of write as good as song as I possibly
can and evoke an emotion and somebody
when they hear it so yeah I actually
want to ask you because country music
has been a topic in the last few months
with little nas accent oh yeah his song
being on a billboard it's great so it
was taken off the Billboard because it
said it's not country enough so what is
country music I just think it's about a
story you know to tell a story to me
country music is about you know telling
the truth in three minutes there's a
saying in Nashville we caught three
chords in the truth
and for me just you know being a being a
storyteller being a songwriter talking
about real life true stuff to me that
that at the core country music is not
just a violin and pedal steel it's it's
more than that it's like it's an emotion
it's a feeling it's a what's a way of
life almost that answers your question
yes Old Town Road is a country song I
mean yeah just with the track beat the
traffic yeah and you collaborate with
Billy Ray Cyrus right you collaborated
with some amazing people on this album
Kelsea Ballerini who else have you done
you've done little big towns on one
track my buddy John parties on another
track and meet and making music by
yourself is fun but when you do
dear friends it just it makes it that
much more fun we gaze all in the studio
together nobody so I was telling some
other Saturday is so easy almost in
country because we're all such good
buddies they're like I remember on this
song that John parties on it's a song
called ain't nothing a beer can't fix
and I literally called him and I was
like hey I have this song I'm gonna send
you the demo and he called me right back
and said wink and I put my buckle on
it's just cool that we have such cool
camaraderie in our genre that we can see
like hey listen a song if you like it
will load for you to feature on it and
then there and then there it is so yeah
and you're singing I watched your video
video yeah and it's such a beautiful
video with your daughter's wearing the
tutee and your wife's in it were you
behind that whole you know the kids
being in the videos complete accident
they were there at the video shoot and
they were wearing like their ballerina
dresses and we were filming a scene and
they'd wiggled out of somebody's arms
and just ran onto the set and they just
kept the cameras rolling and it's cool
when those moments happen that you get
to put them into a music video it'll be
cool to have that one when I'm older it
gets get to watch my kids being in a
music video how long have you known your
wife well we've been to the same school
since first grade um I think we kind of
knew who each other were about third
grade and then really became friends
like middle school so feel the love
through your music when you talk about
her I'm curious as being you know she's
your wife how would you describe her in
terms of being part of your life just
like the most amazing support system the
most amazing person to bounce ideas off
the person that really calms me down
it's such a crazy life if I'm nervous
before so I just call Lauren and she's
like babe you're gonna kill it
just that's all you got to think about
you're gonna kill it she's been such
such a trooper I remember the first year
on the road in 2012 we did like 260
shows that year and she rode the bus
with me and eight of my band members for
a solid year and she after that she's
like I'm never doing that again but just
know that I did that but she's
incredible such an incredible person and
talking about the crazy life you have a
one-year-old and a three-year-old
how is fatherhood it's changing ever
changing I used to not be a super
responsible human being and now I'm a
very responsible person and I feel like
my patience is way way better than it
used to be and my kids have made me a
total
total different person for the better so
a lot of that and you were on Sesame
Street
yes are you now like the popular dad
they they must think you're the coolest
person yes I mean I grew up watching
Sesame Street but I think my kids are a
little bit too young to have grown up on
that so before we before we went up to
do Sesame Street I was showing my kids
all the old videos on YouTube and
getting them really excited and got him
some like you know little puppets and
and all this kind of stuff and we went
up there and we'll agree and hate I
absolutely had beat AMA thought it was
like to go into Disney World but it was
amazing